hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and um
I see we have
all kinds of
questions here
uh let's see where should we start
um
there's one from Aaron here why were
only a few species domesticated could
any species be domesticated are humans
domesticated
interesting
so
you know I think that what does it mean
to be domesticated
it means the the the the the
critters are doing things that people
sort of want them to do and they are uh
kind of operating in some constrained
environment they're living in a house
they're you know operating as um uh as
as things you can ride they're doing
this or that thing that is sort of set
up for to be useful for human purposes
it's kind of like the animal version of
technology in technology you're taking
raw material in the physical world and
you're setting it up to be useful to
humans or in in sort of physical
technology that's what you're doing and
I I think the the case with you know
animals can you take a lizard and make
it useful for human purposes or is the
lizard just going to do a lizard thing
which isn't really what humans want it
to do now it's worth realizing that that
it could be the case
that the you know it's sort of a two-way
thing because you know let's say you
want the mouse is going to go around the
mouse wheel and it's going to do that
for its Mouse reasons so to speak and if
that's useful to us as humans great
one might imagine you know is there
something that a snake might do
naturally I mean there might be things
you can extract from a snake or
something I you know it's uh or from the
the body of a snake or whatever but um
you know are there things that a snake
might do that might be sort of useful to
a human I suppose one could imagine some
some terrible thing where you know there
are snake Warriors where you send them
off to go you know bite the right person
or the wrong person or whatever
um and and that then one might think of
that as sort of a domesticated snake
because doing something that we sort of
somebody wants it to do so I think the
the question is when can you get
Critters to do things that we humans
want them to do and those may be things
like uh
um and and um
and when not now I suppose you know when
you keep animals in a zoo for example
You're simply by physical constraints
sort of getting the animal to be in a
place which is useful for you know
coming to visit the animal or whatever
um and uh that's a little different from
the domesticated case where the animal
just decides oh I'm going to do this
sort of seems to intrinsically with its
own free will decide yes I'm going to be
a horse that um takes the rider to go
over a you know a bunch of jumps or
something like this
so
the question is when when can that work
when can it not work and my impression
is that a lot of things where there's a
whole sort of process of learning how to
train certain kinds of animals that's
been figured out for some kinds of
animals it's not been figured out for
others is it abjectly impossible for the
others or is it just we haven't figured
out how to do it I'm not completely sure
um I think that one can imagine some
very strange sort of uh things where you
know in very small animals like insects
one knows how to kind of instrument the
insect brain and put actual sort of
electrodes in the right places in the
brain to get the insect to do different
kinds of things that's that's something
that gets progressively more difficult
with uh animals with bigger brains and
more complicated setups and so on but
one could imagine you know what's the uh
this question of you know can you train
the animal from the outside to have the
the sort of the intent to do the right
thing and and take the writer over the
over the horse jumps or whatever else or
you know do you end up with a situation
where you know in the brain of the horse
or something you've uh there's
electrodes that make it think that this
is a good thing to do so to speak
so I think that's a this gets very sort
of philosophical because it's kind of
like if we imagine that we as a matter
of our own free will want to do this
this and this
and then somebody somehow we have some
electrode in our brain that is making us
want to do these things at what point do
we really internally want to do it or is
it the outside control that's making us
want to do it remembering that there are
plenty of things that we want to do as a
result of external things like we get
hungry and we want to do this and that's
something which is not you know hunger
is well it is ultimately a brain
function but it's a little bit now that
may be a bad example because I think the
brain directly senses things like
glucose levels
um and so in a sense that's directly
happening in the brain but it's not
happening at the kind of thinking level
of the brain it's happening more at the
pure sensory input level of the brain
um and maybe maybe that's so different
than if you see a particular thing you
know you see the Giant ad for the the
whatever it is the the cookie or
something and then you say I want a
cookie
um you know maybe that's me maybe that's
the same type of thing
but I guess that the question
of you know how do you successfully
domesticate some some kind of Critter I
I think that the real issue is is there
an alignment between the thing that you
human want the Critter to do and sort of
the thing it naturally does
that is there are creatures that really
want to be kind of Lone creatures that
just go off and do that thing there are
creatures that want to be in packs and
maybe if the creatures want to be in
packs we can kind of insert ourselves as
a pseudo pack member so to speak and
it's like hey you know normally you'd be
hunting you know you'd be um uh sort of
hunting in a pack but um actually you
know there's a human Handler who's going
to give you the same close enough to the
same kinds of signals that um you will
sort of follow the human as you would
follow the rest of the pack
and I think uh my my guess is that in
most cases one can sort of trace this
kind of um training so to speak to
uh to some kind of hack on what the
animal is normally doing now I don't
know there are famous examples of I
don't know ducks following
uh what is it baby ducklings and
ducklings following ducks and things and
what are they actually following and I
think it's the orange beak is the
critical thing or something and uh so
you know you just have an orange piece
of paper and they'll follow that too and
the question is how do you sort of get
the how do you take the natural
behavioral characteristics of animals
and sort of hack those enough to get
them to do what you want now in a sense
there's a question asked are humans
domesticated you know I think that is a
funny thing because the fact is that
that we all learn you know in in very
early life we all learn sort of the the
nature of the environment that we happen
to be in and certain kinds of things uh
certain kinds of things seem to have to
be actively taught some things we
naturally learn I don't know whether I
mean I think like learning to walk or
something like this my guess is that
that there isn't uh you know people will
certainly try and actively teach kids to
walk and so on but my guess is that
that's not strictly necessary that that
would sort of happen naturally maybe you
have to see examples of other people
walking I'm not sure but um uh you know
I think that the the question of how
um
how we humans get quotes domesticated
um you know I I it's certainly the case
in in very early life that if you are
living out in the jungle so to speak
versus you're living in some you know
living in an apartment in the city or
something you'll end up with you know
different characteristics really quite
early in life and and later on you might
be able to learn the sort of the
crossover between those things but there
will be sort of a natural uh kind of
imprinting of of some something pretty
early on depending on what environment
you're in and I think that that uh in a
sense in a sense the the role of kind of
education is can be seen perhaps some a
little bit cynically as some form of
domestication so to speak and in the
following sense that you know some part
of education is kind of letting people
teaching people how to operate in some
Society or culture that's been set up in
a certain way and that's in a sense
domestication to that kind of society or
culture and uh people sort of left their
own devices and not sort of educated to
no common things with everybody else
who's to say what what they would do now
you know I I personally tend to think
that sometimes education goes rather
overboard in you know we all end up
having certain ways of thinking for
ourselves and uh if you domesticate too
much the humans so to speak you end up
that they all just think the same way or
don't think very much at all for
themselves and that seems like a bad
thing to me although it's clear from the
point of view of the whole of society
that if everybody was thinking about all
kinds of different things all the time
and nobody was doing anything coherently
with anybody else that that would not
lead to a coherent Society so to speak
so you know it's clear that there that
that that's something that we as humans
have achieved is this notion of sort of
a coherent society and that does seem to
require some amount of sort of common
education so to speak
so anyway a a strange answer this
question about domestication I I don't
really know
you know as I say I think that the way
you can tell whether a species is likely
to be domesticatable is what is its
natural way of Behaving and then how
does that map into the ways of Behaving
that we humans want to get out of that
species so to speak and I suppose it's
the case that maybe there's good
examples of this I don't immediately
think of one
where in the course of human history we
humans have wanted different kinds of
things I mean I suppose uh at various
times yeah when when agriculture was
starting up and people needed oxen to
you know pull plows and things like this
I'm not sure that they have been needed
for anything for any there wasn't
necessarily a human purpose for those
animals
um before that piece of sort of
technology that piece of of cultural
development had happened
and I suppose uh uh you know there may
be things you know if we learn better
how to communicate with animals maybe
there will be a whole other uh you know
raft of kind of domestication so to
speak of animals maybe it will be the
case that you know instead of having the
um
um
you know the watchdog or something
you'll have the um you know it will turn
out that raccoons are really good at
being uh you know at hanging out and
being able to tell you the next morning
you know what happened at night in this
area so to speak and that might be a a
useful way to use those creatures which
one could only do if one could
communicate with them and say Hey you
know give us the report of what happened
um it's uh you know in raccoons or
whatever that one that would then
translate into something that will be
understandable to humans we don't know
how to do that yet
um and uh it remains I've talked about
this a whole bunch because I find it a
really interesting question it's sort of
the communication with alien
intelligence you know what is the view
of the world by a raccoon and is it
translatable into the view of the world
by human you know in in the case of
humans we do okay maybe not perfectly at
translating between sort of different
kinds of human cultures and environments
but we haven't gotten very far except
for sort of of General emotional states
and communicating with most kinds of
animals
anyway a few thoughts on that
um
let's see O'Brien is commenting does
conditioning have to anything to do with
domestication yeah I I think that um uh
in you know the kind of pavlovian idea
so so you know this this notion of Ivan
Pavlov I think and the uh what was it
late to 1800s I believe
um did this experiment where you know
ring a bell feed the dog
and pretty soon the um
you ring the bell and the dog will start
salivating thinking it's going to get
food even though the food is not yet an
Evidence and that's kind of a a
conditioning of uh kind of teaching the
dog something but I tend to think
that
conditioning only goes so far I might be
wrong but but you know if you if you do
something where you put this whole
harness on some kind of creature I don't
know what a a um
uh
uh what can I say I mean you know you
try and condition a
um a finch to talk like a parent it's
just not going to work because it
doesn't have the right syringe structure
or whatever it is to to talk like that
similarly I I think that um there are
behavioral characteristics of animals
that are so sort of deeply burnt in I
doubt you can condition them away maybe
I'm wrong you know that's a question for
humans is you know can we learn anything
and I think the answer is there are
limits to what we can learn
so for instance uh one of the questions
when you have a thing like a helicopter
or something you're trying to fly it and
it's got certain controls
you know we humans are capable of
controlling helicopters when people
tried experiments with with what we now
call drones you know quadcopters and
things like that back a long time ago
they were not controllable by humans now
clearly if you have enough automated
assistance and you've got a flight
controller that's doing most of the work
well then they're controllable by humans
but the question is raw just like you
know if we humans if you strapped onto
US humans ate legs and you said control
these and this in that way there's
probably a point at which we just can't
do it we just don't have the perhaps
Hardware or other capabilities to be
able to do it another example in
language
you know there's always a question what
language is understandable you know
somebody can talk in very long sentences
they can write these giant sentences you
know what what features of language
can we learn and what can we not
you know it tends to be the case that if
you look at language that people
actually use there's for example a limit
on the number of sub Clauses so you say
the cat
which
uh chased the mouse which ate the cheese
which did this which did that Etc et
cetera et cetera the you know if you
were to think about kind of the the
parse structure of that sentence it
would be that would be a noun phrase for
I think yes the cat it's a it's a
qualifier of the of the cats and if you
drew sort of the tree that represents
that that piece of grammar it would be
deeper deeper deeper down the tree Sub
Sub Sub sub clauses
we humans lose it after about five about
depth five now can you could you train
yourself to go deeper
maybe maybe there's a way of chunking it
so that you can uh sort of take into
your memory and sort of compress into
one chunk the thing that you heard first
and so on maybe not I'm not sure I'm not
sure what limits there are on sort of
what's learnable another example that
I've been exposed to quite a bit is
graphs and networks where you have kind
of a you know you've got a bunch of
nodes that represent I don't know sort
of people and then you're joining them
by by lines to represent who's friends
with who and or you try and use that to
represent sort of the flow of data in a
program or something like this and
you'll end up with these very
complicated graphs and the question is
when can humans think in terms of those
graphs for me that's been important in
recent times because our physics project
is deeply based on graphs and hypographs
and so on and so we're routinely
generating these huge graphs and it's
like when can we humans understand
what's going on and we get sort of an
assist by having by laying out these
graphs if the graphs have certain
regularities we lay them out so they
sort of remind us of something which is
like a smooth surface or something like
this and then we're kind of off and
running but if we have uh you know a
graph in the Raw I think it's pretty
hard for humans to understand and I've
been interested in this because in doing
computational language design sort of
the big question is you're trying to
make a language which humans can
actually understand because the whole
point of a computational language is to
bridge between what's in our human minds
and what computers can do and there's
much more that computers can do that is
not stuff that we understand in our
minds in fact even by that statement I'm
making the claim that there are things
we wouldn't really be able to condition
ourselves to do
you know it's it's some like I think in
the in the Dune Universe for example
where they you know Outlaw AIS they have
this notion of um of of humans who can
do computation
and where they've sort of taught
themselves they've pumped themselves up
to the point where they can sort of
compute things that normally just a
computer for us just an electronic
computer can do so I mean there's this
question could you get you know actually
this is a good example of of
conditioning you couldn't achieve I
think could you get a person you know
you you say uh you you give them all
kinds of conditioning you give them
candy if they did it right you do you do
something terrible if they get it wrong
whatever
um can you teach them to multiply six
digit numbers instantly
the answer will be no I think you know
whatever you do however motivated the
person is most people won't be able to
do it it just isn't consistent with
human brain hardware and so on
so again I think that when it comes to
these behavioral characteristics like
can you get I mean I I think there's a
fine line between what's uh a question
of what you choose to do versus what
you're capable of doing you know the
Ducks walking in line the ducklings
walking in line so to speak I don't know
whether uh the the things where they
might just not be able to do it or they
might say I don't want to do that type
thing I'm not sure that there's you know
I'm not sure how how far apart those
things are anyway a few thoughts on that
um
let's see oh okay this is on the subject
of this
this topic and then we'll go to other
topics here
um
uh
okay let's see
uh www says
since an octopus has nine brains each
in one leg how does it see the world
well you know this question about
multiple brains you know we have this
ganglia which are little sort of uh
collections of nerve cells you know we
have those in in
I think in the reflex arcs in our spinal
cord and things like that there are
there are things where you'll have
something you know you touch something
hot and you pull your hand away I I if I
remember correctly that doesn't have to
go all the way to your brain for that to
start happening there are things in
before the the nerves have gotten all
the way to your brain to get processed
there there are ganglia that which are
small clusters of nerves that start
being able to do things now now for
example uh you know if you've got a
really big dinosaur
Stegosaurus I don't know brontosaurus
whatever whatever the surviving kinds of
dinosaurs and surviving I don't mean in
the sense of Extinction at the at the KT
boundary I mean when I was a kid there
were all kinds of names of dinosaurs
that people said oh yeah there's the
brontosauruses or whatever and then
later on people said that's paleontology
is wrong you know there were three
different skeletons and they were all
connected together and they're really
different species but some Museum put
them all together and said it was a
diplodocus or something so so I say
these dinosaurs might have gone extinct
in the nomenclature of paleontology if
not you know they've been extinct for 65
million years or more
um as as actual creatures but anyway if
you're a big enough dinosaur the and
you're trying to walk the speed of nerve
impulses presumably in dinosaurs is
pretty much the same as it is in US
humans and it you just need to uh in
fact I think the same is true in in uh
in animals today you need to do
something with your back legs so to
speak even though the impulse the nerve
impulse from your brain doesn't have
time to get there
um in the time that you know you need to
to make that walk you know I I know it's
the case in fact that even even animals
where you you know disconnect the brain
you can still get walking motion to
happen so there are these ganglia and so
on is that are sort of in the in the
mini brains that are causing certain
things to happen to peripheral objects
like legs and so on even independent of
sort of the control of the central brain
so I I suspect in things like octopuses
octopodes or whatever they you want to
call them uh the the I think the
official plural of octopus is is
octopodes because I think it's a Greek
word and and that would be how it would
pluralize at least an ancient Greek
um but in any case the the um
uh this question of of sort of having
these separate sort of ganglia
controlling each each tentacle
um is uh yeah that's a I mean that's
something that
is now you you then could ask does that
ganglion have a view of the world you
know just like we think in our brains we
have kind of a a representation of the
world and the mind that's in our brains
does the ganglion of tentacle 7 of the
octopus have a view of the world based
on what's happened to the octopus
tentacle probably yes
you know in terms of different views of
the world
uh for example in let's say insects or
trilobites for that matter
they have compound eyes so just as we
are forming not one but two images for
our two different eyes of the world they
have a little omotidia and they might
form a hundred low resolution images of
the world and so that actually they're
not they're not Imaging in the same way
that we are with the lens of the eye and
so on they're just sensing light levels
in different directions
um and so then you could ask well can
you synthesize a view of the world from
that so for example there's the question
you know if you've got a moving object
and for us it's like in our eyes
connected to you know the the on the
retina there's an array of cells maybe
uh on the order of what uh it's about 10
million cells I guess
um that are the the light sensitive
cells on our retina and then those from
those cells there's a bundle of nerves
goes through the optic nerve so at every
position on the retina there'll be
different nerves in the optic nerve that
are taking the the light signal from
that part of our retina and putting it
into a particular part of our primary
visual cortex in the back of our head
um the uh yes it's a design bug
presumably that our primary visual
cortex is the back of our head when our
eyes are at the front of our head I
don't know exactly how that happened
evolutionarily
um but uh I mean
usually what happens in biology is it
starts off well you can kind of make it
work that way and then biology finds a
way to kind of pile on other perhaps
even useful functionality as a result of
the kind of arbitrary decision that was
made so perhaps there's useful
functionality that's been piled onto
that that fact but anyway the point is
that that we've got individual nerve
cells that are looking at different uh
that are connected to different parts of
our retina whereas in the case of a
compound I you've actually got different
light sensitive pieces that different
sort of mini eyes that are all having to
be synthesized together
so now the question would be for the
octopus was it with its separate
tentacle you know mini brains
um does it have a coherent view of space
for example uh you know or is it the
case that it's you know that the fact
that it's separate tentacles are
separately operated in some sense causes
it to not synthesize an overall view of
space hard to know be fascinating to
have the discussion with an octopus if
we could do the translation
the um
I think
um
yeah no I I mean this question of of
what um
uh I was going to say I mean in some
sense
our
species has you know seven billion
whatever it is eight billion brains in
our species and one could ask so how
does that cause us as a species to see
the world
and it's complicated because we have you
know within our brains there are
different parts of our brains that are
connected by sort of high bandwidth
connections of of um of nerve cells and
so on between all of us different humans
the the communication bandwidth is
considerably lower because it's just
things like us talking to each other or
reading what gets written or seeing a
picture or something it's much lower
bandwidth but yet somehow
in some first approximation and the
level of approximation is is the cause
of much geopolitics
um you know we have a coherent view of
the world now of course in reality uh
you know not everybody has the same kind
of view of the world and and what's
important in the world and so on and
what things are relevant to pay
attention to in the world and so on and
uh somebody uh might say you know that's
a that's a magnificent uh treescape or
something and somebody else might say I
don't really notice that all I notice is
the road that's going through it or
whatever else it is
um so you know this this question of you
know does does one maintain coherence
for the whole species and that's that's
sort of something where
um you know I I guess it's an
interesting question whether if you're a
species that has you know a substantial
mini brain could your mini brain just
disagree with your main brain
um and I think the answer that is
probably yes
in the sense that there will be
essentially reflexes that the mini brain
wants to wants to execute that the main
brain says no no that's a really bad
idea there might be something where you
know you you would you would want to put
that foot or whatever or that tentacle
in that place but the main brain which
has a broader view of reality will will
say to that once I say to that tentacle
no don't do that now I think what
typically happens in other systems is
there's an initial kind of oh you're
going to do that and then then maybe the
you know in in you know half a half a
second later or something when the
signal if you're a very big animal when
the signal gets there from your main
brain maybe it overrides that I'm not
sure and one could take an analogy to
that of what some things that happen in
sort of human to human communication are
much much slower time scales
um yeah Brian comments every animal has
different capabilities with their own
advantages and disadvantages dolphins
are fast but they're not fast on land
for sure
um
uh Kira
is asking uh
would you agree that humans are the most
flexible and adaptable
species on Earth
interesting question I don't know
that would be my assumption humans have
one really critical idea or achievement
that we don't think any other species
has
which is the ability to communicate
abstract thoughts from one individual to
another
there are other species that communicate
you know bees have little dancers that
sort of communicate things about which
way the honey is and you know there are
other kinds of sort of uh communication
mechanisms but humans seem to be able to
have the only species that through the
medium of language
has this ability to communicate complex
abstract thoughts abstract
representations of the world independent
of the world itself and so on that that
seems to be the unique sort of uh
um
you know secret source of us humans is
that ability to to to communicate those
things which means that we get to build
up over the course of generations and so
on or even uh in an individual lifetime
through sort of being able to capture
what one's thinking in in tangible form
and so on we're able to build up these
huge towers of capabilities in a way
that we don't see any other animals
doing we don't see
um
a uh we don't see this kind of
multi-generational building up of things
like the technology stack that we humans
have or the knowledge stack that we
humans have
um I'm sure there are minor examples in
in primates for instance of where
there's some ability to build up over
Generations but it's nothing compared to
what we humans have and it seems that
language the richness of human language
is what allows us to do that I would
argue that if we look at the sort of Arc
of evolution uh well you know one thing
to say is the first thing one needs
that's sort of a key thing to make
biology work at all is DNA and the
ability to do genomic sort of to carry
Knowledge genomically from one
generation to the next
um and then the very idea that within a
single lifetime of an organism that it
can learn things but then the
multi-generational learning that we
humans have done is is something as I
say quite unique uh through the medium
of human language I would like to claim
that computational language happens to
be the thing that I've spent a large
part of my life developing the ability
to to represent things in a kind of
systematic computational way that's
understandable both the humans and to
computers that that is at some level
another stage in this progression that
goes from sort of the genomic story of
you remember things just because of your
genome from from generation to
generation to your your sort of learning
things uh memory and within a single
generation to this idea of human
language but the issue with human
language is to reabsorb human language
in the Next Generation you've got to go
to school for 12 years or whatever it is
you've got it's a very slow process to
kind of internalize the um the meaning
of something which was sort of learned
by a previous generation the thing
that's really interesting computational
language is this thing that you can kind
of automate that process of absorption
you don't require sort of just going
through the cycles of the human brain to
do that you can you can take an idea and
you can sort of have it be something
that can be tangibly built on I mean as
a practical matter you know when you if
you're doing science or something and
you you have some paper that somebody
wrote It's got all these cool statements
and formulas and things in it if you
want to use that paper normally what
you've got to do is go absorb that in
your brain think how to do it implement
it again for yourself and so on whereas
if it's a computational paper using
computational language you just I mean
the things I write you just click any on
any picture and that gives you the code
that you can copy and you just start
running that code that computational
language code and then you can build on
it and I and I think that this this
ability to do computational language is
kind of a another accelerator for kind
of abilities that one has that is uh you
know it's it's a it's a sort of add-on
to the ability that we humans have had
for hundreds of thousands of years of
dealing with things with with human
language
um but uh human natural language but I
think it's an important accelerator and
it's one where the consequences of that
acceleration are far from what we know
yet I mean in in other words we don't
have we have in many countries pretty
Universal literacy and in in human
language we don't have at all Universal
literacy in computational language we
have attempts to teach low-level
programming languages which is a
different thing and we have you know the
few million people who know wolfen
language for example
um is a is a good start
um and uh it um that's a place where you
get to actually Express things about the
world computationally when that becomes
more Universal and it will although it
may take a while when that becomes more
Universal things will happen as they
happened when literacy in in natural
language became Universal maybe 500
years ago in many countries and so on
and that allowed all kinds of forms of
government and and knowledge transfer
and all sorts of things allowed all
kinds of things enabled all kinds of
things to happen that had not really
been possible before I mean originally
when literacy came in that enabled you
know the the systematic organization of
cities and things like that that was
back in Babylonian times and so on maybe
four thousand years ago or something
um and that's one thing when when some
people can do it that enables some
things when everybody or in a particular
area can do it that enables all kinds of
other things and we're sort of we're
we're we're in still it's only the the
um The Druids the high priests or
whatever who can do computational
language well we like to it's an
increasing collection of people but it's
still a subset of the population among
can't sort of take take computational
language for granted as one can take
writing for granted in in Reading at
least these days I don't know whether
anybody knows how to handwrite anymore
that may be a lost art at some point
soon
um but uh
you know take that for granted
the um
uh okay all sorts of comments here
um
Hoots is commenting other species
communication is domain specific and
ours is universal
I don't know about that I don't know
about that I I you know it's a it's a
mystery what you know if if cockatoos if
we could understand cockatoo Church
language
um
how Universal would it be
if we say I mean if we think about a
computer for example at the lowest level
a computer is very domain specific it
says it has instructions some number of
instructions that say take these two
registers and add their values together
take this thing and take it from this
place in memory and copy it to another
place in memory it's pretty specific
low-level stuff yet the amazing thing
about computation is you can build up
from that low-level stuff and even from
even lower level stuff even from these
incredibly simple computational systems
you can build up all the richness that
we know computation makes possible and
in our physics project it's pretty clear
that it makes possible everything in the
universe it's all sort of computation at
the bottom and so in a sense what the
whole story of computation is you can
build up from these Primitives you can
build up a lot of stuff now you know
humans no doubt in their early
hunter-gatherer days
were sort of domain specific they were
like well I can pick these berries I can
go and Chase the mammoth I can do
whatever it is and the fact that we've
built up this sort of Rich seemingly
Universal ability to talk about things
is a consequence of these layers of of
kind of structure that have been built
into our language now are we in fact
able to talk about anything no we're not
you just go look at in in our kind of
models that have emerged from our
physics project and so on this concept
of the rouliad is this concept of the
the thing that represents sort of the
entangled limit of all possible
computations you can imagine doing
we think that our experience of the
universe is simply us as entities within
the rouliad experiencing rouliad and
that gives us kind of our view of
physics
and so the question is if you plop
yourself down and in a sense we are
seeing the rouliad from a particular
Vantage fight from a particular point in
rural space just as we see the universe
from a particular point in physical
space we're seeing the universe from a
particular point in real space with a
particular kind of description language
we can translate to another description
language we know that's possible because
of universal computation because you can
program one computer to do anything any
anything any other computer can do but
this question of is it readily
understandable to us if we plop
ourselves down with a completely
different description of the universe
that's kind of similar to the question
about octopodes and their multiple
brains you know its view of the Universe
versus our view of the universe but we
can very easily confront ourselves with
a view of the universe that's very alien
I mean in a thing that I've done a lot
of is what I call ruliology the study of
simple rules and what they do there are
simple rules where we sort of
intrinsically understand what they do we
kind of have a way of talking about them
we can turn what those rules do into a
narrative that we humans can understand
or we can just pick a rule at random and
see what it does and many rules say well
that looks interesting maybe it's a good
piece of art maybe it's a good whatever
it it's something where we don't have
that same kind of immediate narrative
understanding of what's going on that we
do with things which are close to our
current points in real space
so in some sense we humans are still
domain specific we live at a particular
place in rural space we have particular
description languages for things and we
can plainly see out there in you know
distant in real space we can jump to
those places in Royal space we will find
it very confusing because we don't have
a good kind of narrative way of
connecting that to things that we
understand so I claim we humans are
still pretty domain specific and I I
think the distinction between us as not
domain specific versus your average
cockatoo
it's not obvious to me what and you know
cockatoos have had the disadvantage that
they don't have technology they've never
been able they don't have a written
language they don't have we don't even
know what their what their spoken
language is like
um and uh you know what could they build
if they'd had the same uh sort of
ability to create concrete things that
we do I don't think we know and I don't
think it's obvious that uh that I mean
as I say the fact that we humans can
talk about lots of kinds of things in
the world
I'm sure that wasn't true 200 000 years
ago and the you know if if we went back
and had a conversation with your average
hunter-gatherer of 200 000 years ago I
think the the universe of discourse that
we would have had would have been quite
limited I mean it's an interesting
question it's an interesting thought
experiment to say you know you're going
back and you're chatting with somebody
from 200 000 years ago what are you
going to talk about
you know you can talk about some
I don't know it's kind of challenging
you can't um
um uh you could ask questions that are
sort of features of of human
characteristics you know uh I don't know
you can ask sort of uh things about what
you do but it's it's it's going to be
very difficult you know if you if you
start saying
um
no do you find those kinds of berries
tasty
that's that's complicated
um you know the you probably can deal
with do you eat those kinds of berries
and not those kinds of berries yeah you
can deal with that I mean again
these are challenges that you have even
today within different groups of people
who have different kinds of interests
and and sort of cultural backgrounds and
so on
um
let's see www is commenting
that the mapping between the world and
brain zones is a simple geometrical
mapping
is this true for a brain leg mapping
yeah
um
you know it's an interesting question if
you look at the and I don't know this is
probably known if you look at a dog for
example that has very smell-based
perception of the world as big
ol-faction system in its brain we don't
have a big one but it uses that much
more
if you look at the layout of the
olfaction system in a dog
what is it like because for us the
sensory systems that we have the ones
that are for touch for example you can
go find the places in the brain where
you're essentially mapping the the
physical geometrical structure of your
surface you know that your fingers your
your feet whatever else are mapped to
particular parts of the brain
geometrically similarly with your eyes
the the position in the retinal image is
mapped to a particular place in the
brain with your ears in our ears it's
the frequency of the sound that is
mapped to a particular position in the
cochlea and then into the auditory
cortex I think is mapped in the same way
so a good question would be which we
don't you know we don't have a good
smell space so to speak we don't know
which smell is close to which other
smell we know you know in visual scene
we can say well that object is close to
that object visually for us we could say
that sound is at a close frequency to
that other sound but in in malfaction
space I don't think we have any clear
mapping and so one thing we could do is
look for a dog for example at what
smells uh
sort of connect to what nearby regions
in the brain maybe that experiment has
been done I don't know
um but that would give us sort of an
interesting way actually now they think
about it but yeah at least as of a few
years ago there was a lot of complexity
in that so uh companies that make
perfume for example have a great
interest obviously in making things that
smell a certain way and it's still
somewhat unclear what all the Dynamics
of how a molecule you know got this
molecule it's a certain shape what is it
going to smell like you know is that
going to smell like a uh you know a lily
or something or is that going to smell
like whatever
um you know based on the shape of the
molecule what is it going to smell like
that's been a hard question to answer
I'm not sure what the most recent work
on that is but but back in not too long
ago it was still not clear whether it
was the sort of the shape the vibration
characteristics of the molecule or all
those kinds of things that that would
affect it but then the question is if
you've got all these molecules they're
all these different shapes how do they
lay out and smell space so to speak and
you know does one get uh when one looks
at the dog's olfaction system you know
do we is it natural you know to a dog it
will be natural oh that smell is like
that other smell just like to us we will
be saying look can't you see that that
thing is really close to that other
thing in physical space
and so I think this idea that
um you know there is coastness surely in
smell space
at least for a dog if not you know not
for us right now that's a different kind
of sensory system
um
let's see
um
all right any more about this type of
topic
and then we can talk about other things
um
all right uh
oh there's a
question from Brady do you think it's
possible we might live inside a cosmic
super organism analogous to the way
microbes live in microbes live inside of
us
well yeah we do I mean that's sort of
the whole ecosystem of the world
and all the different organisms and you
know members of a single species and so
on that's not that different from
microbes you know we know like the the
microbiome and and that we have for
example all the microbes that live in
our gut
they have a whole ecosystem in that
you know in that ecosystem if you start
eating different kinds of things you'll
put different sort of stresses on that
ecosystem and gradually just like if
there's an ice age or something and the
critters with longer fur do better well
same if you start eating only
fruit or something the microbes in your
gut that like that will start to do
better and so on or you know if you take
an antibiotic and you blow up a bunch of
microbes you'll have
um the uh um
you'll have other ones that will sort of
come in that are more adapted to that so
yeah it's a it's a continual thing that
you know we have an ecosystem inside us
of our microbes and you know in the last
several years there's increasing
knowledge of that of that microbiome
ecosystem and the application of sort of
ecological ideas to that and I think
it's uh it's an interesting question
whether it's becoming clear that the
microbiome is is pretty important to
human health and that there's a lot of
sort of feedback mechanisms from what's
happening in the microbiome to what
happens elsewhere in the body and so on
and so it's like you know uh conserve
your microbiome so to speak
um and there's an interesting question
what one can learn and what the
interplay is between that and sort of
ecosystems and the Earth in general and
you know what's important what's not uh
you know in in um uh and and how that in
the case of the microbes it's a sort of
dependence on the scale of the stuff
that's inside you know one person's gut
or something
um and uh it's interesting to see how
that how that Independence works I don't
think the um uh I don't think there's
much in the way of um
I think it's kind of a
many different there's a great diversity
of different kinds of bacteria more
diverse I mean they don't really have
quite the same sort of species
characteristics that um with distinct
species that um that happen in a higher
more complicated organisms
um so you know so it's an even more
complicated story as a result of that
but yeah I think I think the we are a
supernet organism for those for those
microbes and we as individual members of
the ecosystem of the Earth are um a kind
of you know operating within that I
think I think it's um uh
yeah lots of lots of things to say about
that
all right let's see
um
um
oh boy
so many interesting questions here uh
okay all right one more on brains and
then we'll go to something else for a
few minutes uh spare asks is there a way
to tell how much of our intelligence
emerges from high-level brain functions
versus low-level kind of cellular
computation
you know an interesting question when
you're thinking about something how much
of your brain is actually being used
if you were a computer a very small
fraction of the computer is being used
for many kinds of operations
um
in
you know most of the memory of the
computer is not being touched at any
given time uh sometimes you know you're
streaming video or something and there's
lots of pieces of the computer usually
what happens I think with computers and
probably with biological organisms is
once there's a thing you're always doing
it there'll be a special purpose piece
of Hardware that's made to just do that
so for example if you're always
breathing let's say or your heart is
always beating there's going to be some
fairly special purpose thing that's just
going to take care of that and it's the
things where there's sort of general
purpose stuff that are the part of our
brain that we sort of typically think
most about and that's where sort of our
general thinking happens
but I think it's a good question whether
when you're trying to I don't know
figure out some science question write a
piece of code do whatever you know how
much of your brain is actually active
and we know a certain amount about this
from functional MRI imaging and from
looking at sort of which parts of the
brain are are taking power so to speak
which parts of the brain are consuming
uh glucose and so on
um and are active I don't know how
accurately that really tells us how much
is going on and how much that just tells
us this area is more active than that
area but you know the surprising thing
about brains
uh is that they managed to knit together
this sort of single thread of experience
that we believe we have in other words I
might have 100 billion neurons and they
might each be doing what they're doing
but somehow I think I'm having a
definite thread of a coherent experience
and that process that sort of attention
thing that makes us have this coherent
threat of experience that's kind of
knitting together the activities of some
fraction of those hundred billion
neurons how many are active in a given
thought I don't think we have any ideal
idea and I think that that the process
by which we go from all those individual
neurons to a coherent thought
is a very interesting process that is
really a a part of the whole story of
being an observer doing a measurement
you know when we say we're measuring the
the pressure of this gas well by having
some piston somewhere or something what
we're really saying is there are all
these gas molecules and they're all
hitting in all kinds of random places
but we're taking all those separate
impacts and we're turning that into the
overall motion of this piston and so
similarly in our brains we're taking all
of the activity of all those billions of
neurons and we're turning that into oh I
just thought about the color green or
something a coherent thought
so a question you might ask is our
neurons are being sort of correlated to
have that coherent thought if we look at
kind of all the the creatures of the
Earth or the people of the earth to what
extent is the same thing happening or
not
and again you know that's a complicated
issue because there isn't you know at
the level of an individual human we
think or we're thinking definite
thoughts we have definite goals we're
doing definite things when you say at
the level of a country or at the level
of the world how does that work well you
can say a certain amount about that I
don't think it's as coherent as one
could say it is for an individual human
but it's sort of the same kind of
process I think of formation we don't
know really how it works in humans you
know how do you make a decision go left
rather than right
you could be pulling
a billion neurons and saying hey what do
you all think and kind of voting and
eventually the neurons say hey go you
know more of us say go left so go left
whether you know the brain sort of is a
giant democracy like that I don't think
we really know
um I think that um uh this sort of
question of of how how one concentrates
sort of what you might refer to as sort
of the the cellular level computation
how one concentrates that into coherent
thoughts is a key problem of
Neuroscience and you know even
describing that process even describing
what does it mean to concentrate that to
knit together all of those individual
neurons and make it a coherent thought
that's uh uh that that's a sort of
defining what that means and and
understanding that is is really it's an
interesting thing now now obviously we
know a certain amount from artificial
neural Nets we know oh there's this
array of pixels and they all do their
different things and the artificial
neural net probably much like the human
neural Nets forms the thought that it's
a picture of a cat
and so it's going from all those
individual in those individual sort of
uh pixels to this oh and it's it's a
picture of a cat so that's that's but
but how to think about this process in
general of the forming of thoughts and
the cohering of all those individual
neural activities it's that's that's
something I don't think we understand at
all well and it's sort of a key problem
there and you know when we have I don't
know a dream or something you know it's
probably there's probably a certain
amount of random activity going on in
our brains at the level of individual
neurons firing and not firing and you
know getting cleaned out of of the gunk
that's built up during the day or
whatever else it is and and those sort
of random firings we have such a strong
sort of capability to go hear things
together but even if it started as
random firings we say well actually a
definite thing happened we have a
thought about how that worked and so on
let's see
all right just a few more we're having
I'm having fun here at least
um
the uh
oh William asks what's the simplest
possible object okay I have a very
simple answer to that it's a single atom
of existence
a single what we call eem eme in our
model of physics
space is made of all these atoms of
space that are related to each other
connected in a giant Network and that's
sort of the the lowest level
representation of space is as this
collection of relations between atoms of
space
uh we think in this rouliad object
it's doing all these computations but
what is the data structure on which
these computations are acting it is this
thing that is made of atoms of existence
and what what is an atom of existence
well it has really just the only thing
to say about it is
it exists
and it is or we can say it exists
uh and it is unique every atom of
existence is different from every other
atom of existence
and atom's resistance can be related in
certain in you know there are relations
between them but they are distinct they
are they have their own independent
thing if you were into sort of computer
stuff they would have a uuid a universal
unique identifier for example every atom
of space would have one of these
knowing that two atoms of space are
distinct is something that you can't
know this is a complicated issue you as
an observer within the universe can't
know that you have to kind of go outside
the universe to be able to prove that
for sure it's kind of like you can't
prove the consistency of an axiomatic
system from within that system itself
the
um
let's see okay maybe one or two more
here
uh
um
well
as a
since we're on a brains kick today
um Brady comments can you explain why
the default scientific position is that
Consciousness does not rely on quantum
mechanics let's say to me it seems
obvious that at least
that it would at least to some extent
well
quantum mechanics is kind of the theory
that describes how very small things
work and in our model of physics we have
a pretty clear view of how quantum
mechanics works
in
the world of classical physics ordinary
physics sort of definite things happen
you you uh sort of
you drop something it falls in a
definite trajectory
it uh in quantum mechanics there's this
whole uh the whole sort of tree of
possible trajectories and we as
observers uh we only get to be sensitive
to sort of the probabilities of all
those different parts there are many
paths that are intrinsically taken but
we only get to sort of sense some
probabilities across all those different
paths
well
so
kind of what happens is
we
and this is gets a little bit
complicated in our physics project
um
just as we're pretty big compared to for
example ordinary atoms of molecules so
we don't sense a typical you know we
don't when we when we pour some water we
don't say oh look at all those molecules
coming out it's just like a continuous
fluid that just comes out we can
describe in that sort of Continuum way
and that's because we're really big
compared to those molecules and so we
kind of aggregate together those
individual molecules well in what we
call branchial space the space of
quantum branches all these different
sort of Paths of history that can happen
in quantum mechanics we're also pretty
big in barshield space and so we you
know I I should say this word Branch
Hill I I the British version and the
American I can't imitate the American
version
b-r-a-n-c-h-i-a-l branchial whatever I
just I want to clarify it's it's what it
is so so it isn't sort of um uh mangled
by my by my slightly British accent
um the uh
okay so we're pretty big in brown Shield
space as well and so we are in a sense
aggregating across all these different
branches of History so we say most of
the time we just say oh you know this
average kind of thing happens just like
we'd say most of the time we'd say this
average kind of thing happens with
molecules in the water
now there are special things we can do
that kind of drill down just like there
are special things we can do to notice
the water is made of molecules the
special things we can do to notice that
it isn't really the single thread that
happens in in physics it's all these
different threads in different places in
branchial space so there is always
quantum mechanics underneath it's just
we aggregate things together so it
doesn't matter much so now the question
is in our brains
is our brain
is there a description of our brain that
says let's just aggregate everything to
go to classical physics or does it
matter is our brain sensitive to those
multiple branches at some fundamental
level
we don't know for sure
I think that the kind of the activities
of artificial neural Nets and the things
we've learned from machine learning and
so on make it all the more likely that
it really doesn't matter that there is
sort of quantum mechanics underneath in
other words that the the sort of the the
functional aspects of brains depend only
on sort of very aggregated properties of
things like neurons it doesn't matter
that the neuron has lots of
um microtubules on its surface and that
that are doing all kinds of things and
have all kinds of complicated patterns
all that matters is that neuron fired it
generated an electrical signal that was
passed to a neighboring neuron that's
all that matters about a neuron it's the
same thing in a computer for example we
could say do we care about the precise
voltage current characteristics of the
transistors probably not all we really
care is that they switch on or off and
they make you know a binary digital
computer for example so it's a question
of what matters what doesn't what
matters to the kind of large level of
the thoughts we have and what is yes
it's there inside the physics but it
doesn't really matter at the level of
description that we're interested in
about what thoughts we have and so on
so the question of whether
oh for example Let me Give an example
let's say we try and make up a random
number they're going to pick a number at
random well let's say we're uh we're a
critter that is flying around and it
wants to fly around a random path
because if it flew around in a very
regular path its Predators would long
ago have have eaten all of it because
you know if if what happened was that
the the fly that's flying around always
just went in a you know in a in a
backwards forwards backwards forwards
path or or whatever or the or the
creature that was foraging a particular
area of a you know eating a leaf or for
foraging in some area of of uh of land
that if it always went in this precise
spiral you know it's kind of like the
robot vacuum cleaner or something that
goes in the precise spiral as it goes
and explores the room if if you were a
predator of Robot vacuum cleaners
um the robot vacuum cleaners wouldn't
last long because you'd always know it's
going to go in a spiral I know where
it's going to go next I can lie and wait
and pounce and uh eat the robot vacuum
cleaner or whatever or drain its
batteries or whatever I want to do but
in um
so there's a value to having to being
random to doing random things that's a
that's valuable in certain situations to
certain species and so on and so now the
question is where does that Randomness
come from you know when the fly is
flying around seemingly randomly to us
uh you know how to get the randomness
does it in fact leech down to some
Quantum level thing that's uh from which
it's extracting the random it's probably
not because it's very easy to make
Randomness as I've learned in in my
activities of looking at simple programs
and what they do it's actually very easy
to make apparent Randomness just from
things that can be done at the level of
simple computations and so on but that's
a place where you might like to think
that oh is there some sort of quantum
going on and there are effects like for
example the magnetic sensing of that
exists in pigeons maybe it even exists
in us we don't know for sure where you
can directly sense in your brain the
magnetic field of the earth and know
some of which way is North that the way
that happens is almost certainly a
quantum mechanical effect that involves
a sort of a electron spins and trapped
in certain ways and so on and able to be
Amplified by by the brain
so you know so there are quantum kinds
of things now does does quantum
mechanics matter when I have a thought
does it really matter that things are
underlying Quantum actually the thing
that most indicates it doesn't really
matter is that we have definite thoughts
that we've managed to aggregate things
together to the point where instead of
it being the raw quantum mechanical many
many parts of History many different
things going on we say I say definite
things I'm I'm talking to you I've got a
definite stream of words that are being
generated by my brain and that's
something where it is not the case
excuse me the the um it's not the case
that that you're hearing from all the
different parts of my brain all the
different kind of the the giant uh
cacophonous you know um uh non-symphony
or something of of all the different oh
you know the frontal lobe is telling you
this the uh the you know this part of
the hippocampus is telling you this and
um you know instead no we humans sort of
aggregate things into the single thread
and I think for the purpose of that
single thread my guess is the Quantum
effects are not important
um uh there may be some specific areas
just like in in typical experience the
world Quantum effects aren't important
but there are particular things you can
find by looking and that's how quantum
mechanics was discovered there are
particular detailed things you can find
you can amplify whatever if you have the
right kind of equipment and instruments
and make the right kind of measurements
to know that there really are quantum
things going on
let's see
well William asks why is it that we as
observers never see quantum
superpositions
why are superpositions aligned to our
macroscopic observations
well
these different threads of History
they can correspond to different things
happening in the world
and if you slice history at a particular
moment you have all these threads and
these that that that thing that slice at
a particular moment is a superposition
of the different things that are
happening in all those threads of
History
but what we do I think as observers of
that is we just say we're going to
conflate all those things together we're
going to assume they're all the same
we're going to treat them as the same
and it's a little bit subtle because our
brains are branching just the same way
the universe is branching so saying
we're going to treat them as the same
it's like the the two octopus brains on
its different tentacles or something are
just going to conclude that their view
of the world is the same actually I
suppose the um uh
um
reminds me of a
person oh I don't know this is a
terrible story but but um uh a um a
person I knew who was a um a kind of a a
very interesting
sort of thinker about foundations of
physics in particular quantum mechanics
and um I remember having dinner with him
once and um I was talking about uh
you know the photon it said you can only
understand the photon if you come from a
particular cultural background you know
you're out of luck if you're from a
different you know cultural religious
tradition whatever you won't understand
the photon and it's some uh the um
uh I think
the thing that um
um uh this there's this question of
could we
so our brains are branching merging Etc
it turns out the big fact about quantum
mechanics is that conflating these
branches of History
is not inconsistent
in other words things it works out to
just assume these branches of History
are the same for purposes of what are
what we are perceiving in the universe
so in other words we can successfully
say there's a single branch of History
now you know it's interesting question
if you're a giant creature that's you
know
huge spread out creature Across the
Universe you're light year across
and by the way a black hole a few black
holes form inside you
and there are event Horizons which which
restrict the information flow uh between
different parts of you
then the question would be
what
you know you will no longer be able to
form a coherent view of your world
because there are parts of your brain
effectively that are separated off by
event Horizons and so I think this
question of whether you know when can
you form a coherent view of the world
when is it consistent to form a coherent
view of the world probably won't be if
there are a bunch of black holes in your
brain so to speak but the the fact is
the non-trivial fact it's related to
this thing we call causal invariance in
our physics theory of physics
um is uh leads to this fact that you it
is okay it is consistent to make certain
kinds of conflations
and so I think
what one could imagine is could there be
a brain
where one intrinsically experiences
quantum mechanics where these different
branches of history have not been
conflated and where sort of one part of
your brain is thinking one thing is
happening one part of your brain is
thinking another thing is happening or
more locally in uh you know really it's
these different branches of History not
oh it's a different place in space where
one thing has happened versus another
but let's say you could spatialize it
which is sort of what's happening when
you do an interference experiment or
something like that you're spatializing
what is essentially different branches
of history and saying that that that
that's some and so
let's imagine you could do that maybe
you could imagine some
people whatever who've managed to sort
of train themselves if it's possible to
kind of think multiple thoughts at a
time by using sort of these Quantum
branches now it's sort of an interesting
thing because when we talk about quantum
computers and things we imagine in the
brain of the quantum computer it really
is following all these paths the problem
with quantum computers and so on is that
they're interfacing to us humans and we
humans want a definite answer we want a
definite thing to have happened so the
question then comes up could you have
something where our fundamental Human
Experience is quantum
and that I suppose is raised by the
possibility of having sort of quantum
mechanics as important in the brain
could we have a Quantum experience of
the world our normal experience of the
world is this coherent one way this
thing happens then this thing happens
and that thing happens rather than this
experience where there are many parts of
history and they're all sort of
simultaneously occurring that will be
the sort of quantum experience of the
brain now it could be the case that if
you really want a quantum computer to
work you have to have a Quantum Observer
so it's like you have to be sort of you
have to be in this strange kind of state
where you're you're thinking multiple
things I don't even know how to describe
it it's a it's a different um it's a
it's an experience that we don't
normally have I mean I think you know
people say that uh people with various
kinds of um uh psychological psychiatric
kinds of issues can sort of have
multiple personalities multiple things
going on I don't think those happen uh
simultaneously I don't think it's like
like one part of the brain is acting
like this person one part of the brain
is acting like that doesn't seem like I
don't think that's how it works but but
maybe it is
um and you know then then there's the
question of sort of okay but you know as
humans we have for example a single
stream of of yakking with talking we
don't have as I was mentioning before
it's not like oh we've got part of a
word comes from this part of a brain and
then another part of word comes from
another part of the brain and you're
having 17 conversations at the same time
all being communicated on this channel
that it's human language because human
language doesn't work that way human
language has is this single threaded
thing where we say this then this then
this it's kind of like you know when we
look at communication between computers
uh typically computers will they'll send
a packet that's oh there's a bunch of
video information that's here oh the
next thing is a piece of email up the
next thing is this they don't sort of
scramble those things now maybe at the
very low level for various kinds of
transmission reasons there is some
scrambling that can happen in certain
cases but mostly it's this thing about
there's a sequence of things that get
sent and and I think that's uh you know
so in the end uh sort of it's
interesting thing to speculate on
whether there's a a form of Human
Experience
that is sort of a fundamentally Quantum
humor form of human experience that uh
at least the most of us don't have and
so and and if we were to describe it in
language what does it feel like to have
that experience I I don't know that's a
very challenging thing to describe
um
let's see so William is commenting could
it be then the quantum mechanics just
involves higher dimensions of time the
fact that quantum mechanics is
comprehensible to us because then
because we're trying to understand
higher dimensional time from a single
dimensional thread of experience
well Dimensions is like it's like if
you're laying out a graph
a network and your network is is a giant
grid
let's say a two-dimensional grid you say
well it's a it's like a two-dimensional
thing three dimensions you know it's a
it's a giant uh a cubicle thing for
example that's those are dimensions but
what happens in uh and you could then
talk about you know if time had these um
instead of going in a single thread as
we usually experience it had was in some
grid that would be sort of a
two-dimensional time but what we
actually think is that time is this kind
of graph it's not one-dimensional it's
not two-dimensional it's a graph of
possibilities and what we're doing is
we're compressing that graph down to a
single thread
um and yes that's a that's a thing that
we're doing that approximates that full
graph which is the full story of quantum
mechanics to that single thread and we
are understanding it by making that
conflation just like we're understanding
I don't know the the flow of Water by
just talking about the continuous flow
of water rather than saying and this is
where all the the trillions and
trillions of molecules go
let's see
um
oh my
I thought I'd finally
sort of gotten rid of this cough
I think it may have been um
uh
it
um I've noticed I've been working on a
history project
and uh I have a lot of antiquarium books
and I also happen to be allergic to mold
and so history project has a serious
occupational hazard of uh the fact
you're getting out all these all these
old books and um in fact just yesterday
I was I have a storage place where I
keep a lot of of all the material and I
was there and it was one of the um I'm
not a big one for wearing masks to avoid
viruses but this was a case we're
wearing a mask to avoid the mold worked
out pretty well
um
well let's see I think we should
probably wrap up here because I've got
to go there's something with my day job
but let me just see if there's any quick
questions here that I might be able to
address
Aaron asks
why do my glasses get foggy but my
eyeballs do not
okay my theory is that's a simple
question to answer
um
I think
the
uh
you know the surface of your eye is
continuously covered by a film of I mean
there's a there's a film of liquid I
think that's generated by you know the
tear ducts and so on and I I think
the reason that you don't get
uh hmm
see this is always what happens these
questions which I think are really easy
turn out to be not quite as easy as I
expect
I mean
glasses get foggy because
they are cold if you look at an infrared
picture of a person your skin is hot
your glasses are cold
um
and
when there's there's water vapor in the
air
the
um
uh at a colder temperature that will
condense into something that is like
droplets of water even though that
wouldn't happen
um
hmm okay well maybe you've stumped me
there a little bit I have to I have to
think this one through
um
uh yeah I mean says cyber is commenting
fog concrete droplets on a wet surface
uh yeah I mean clearly okay that's
that's a good point that you know a
droplet is a piece of liquid
and once you have liquid any droplet
that forms it's just going to be
integrated into the liquid so it's not
going to be a separate thing where
you've got a solid surface that is like
your glasses and then you've got
droplets on the solid surface yeah I
think I think that's right that that's
that's right that's that's probably the
cleanest thing to say
the reason that things get foggy is
because you've got a bunch of
essentially fog which is you know
droplets of water on on your glasses and
when light goes through those droplets
the because the droplets are small the
light is scattered in all kinds of
different directions but if that droplet
which is a liquid
came was was on the surface of a liquid
the molecules in that drop that will
just all spread out and be part of the
liquid
um and so that uh and so that means that
they won't will no longer have this
characteristic that they are tiny little
things that scatter light in all these
different directions
um
and uh Paul is commenting not not to
forget that eyelids eyelids act as as
windshield wipers yeah
um
yeah yes yes no doubt and that's right
if you have a little thing in your eye
it'll it'll tend to get um uh
sort of moved around by that all right
well I think the the the there's
actually a bunch more that I think I
have to say about this but maybe uh
maybe for another time
um all right well thanks uh
um
uh
thanks for lots of interesting questions
and uh
I have to say as I as I try and explain
stuff to you all uh I understand things
a bunch better
so and there are quite a number of
things today where uh I think my
understanding just improved quite a bit
uh like for example the the comment
about
um uh the relationship between
measurement and observer Theory and the
coherence of uh of neurons in the brain
I had not really put those things
properly together before so thanks for
stimulating those kinds of thoughts and
um uh and perhaps helping to generate
more coherence in my thinking than would
otherwise Exist by virtue of the fact
that maybe all those independent
thoughts have to get concentrated into a
kind of a stream of live streaming
anyway thanks a lot and uh
see you another time
bye for now